[Music]
when you look back at the sabbaticals
you've taken right so
nine or ten two-month sabbaticals now
when you look at the sabbaticals that
have recharged you the most
versus the sabbaticals that have
recharged you the least
do you see any
patterns or do you see any
characteristics
that have some
explanatory power for you
that's a really really great question
this past sabbatical was incredibly
recharging
and um
you know it came after the the
year that time forgot you know 2020
and um
the
in 2020 i bought um i got into cycling
and um
[Music]
as i said in my away message during this
past sabbatical i said
something like um
may your summer be filled with fireflies
and s'mores
for me i hope to have it filled with
weeding in my garden
and cycling in the mountains
and writing and working i'm working on a
new book
and working on my new book and
i slept
well
i ate well
and i rested
well
and i exercised my mind
was a new book and i traveled i saw a
family that i hadn't seen in 18 months
i spent two weeks on the coast of
california and a lovely beach house
and my kids each came to visit and
cycled through
um which was lovely and
that so if i would say there's a pattern
of of sabbaticals that are done right
it's um
it's a focus on mind and body
and it's resting both and taking care of
both
for sabbaticals that did not go so well
i
would say the pattern is to load it up
with expectations like i'm going to
finish a book
or i'm going to read this these 10 books
or
i'm going to write a new business plan
or
i'm going to travel to europe and see
all these friends and then travel back i
mean these are all examples that my
clients have given me
and
you know the number one rule
in sabbatical is sabbath
rest
rest
the body needs rest the mind and heart
need
rest
right
that's just that's the simplest way i
can put it for you
do you have or could you tell us if if
there are any examples
any
examples of
epiphanies or breakthroughs
ahas of any type that resulted from
being fully rested when you came back to
quote-unquote normal life
the epiphany could have happened during
the sabbatical but let's just say
something
and what i'm trying to do here is
to speak to people who
have disallowed themselves from taking
breaks to try to
sell
this might be the wrong way to approach
it but some of the payoff of resting
does that make sense to me it does it
does and i'm looking away and i'm
getting uncomfortable in my body because
what i'm feeling is the impulse which
i think you're giving voice to which is
to make sabbatical productive
right
and ah
if that at all feels resonant
that's the problem
you know when i was saying before let go
of those expectations that's part of
what i'm talking about here
um
okay so there's an image that i write
about in my first book uh something that
occurred to me in 2001 when i was lying
on the
ground at the bottom of the grand canyon
which by the way if you really want to
disconnect go to the bottom of the grand
canyon
you're four billion years into the past
it's an extraordinary experience
and i'm lying on the beach there may or
may not have been um some alcohol
involved
and i'm staring up at the sky
and someone lying next to me says oh
shooting star
and i begin trying to stare at the
shooting stars
and i'm looking and i'm looking and i'm
looking and it's driving me crazy
because i can't see them
and then finally someone says stop
looking for them
and i rest my eyes
and with peripheral vision this is true
fact all of a sudden i can start
catching the motion
and that's an image i would give you for
sabbatical
people who go into sabbatical with the
plan too hey i'm going to lose 10 pounds
b i'm going to get into real good shape
see i'm going to finish that book
typically after
farting around for a week not getting
anything done start to feel terrible
and then it becomes this like voice of
you're wasting time i can't believe you
did this what's the matter with you
you're failing at sabbatical
right which is insane
but if we go back to that notion of
sabbath
which is you know in the jewish
tradition you know
disavow or disconnect from anything that
is electrical right put your keys down
put your money down
rest
there's something very very profoundly
holy
in rest
now i know i'm swimming upstream
everybody wants to be productive
you